Я хотів би подякувати засобам масової
інформації тому що в цьому році набагато
більше була інформованість абітурієнтів
а також ще може на сьогоднішній день
здається трохи дивним великому колективу
найбільшого оператора державного
Укртелекому який допомагав реалізувати
експерименти електронний вступ 2011 Ще
раз висловлюю всім учасникам цього
процесу щиро подякував за активну творчу
роботу за державницьку позицію І лише
203 тисячі випускників пройшли
тестування А загалом подали документи
понад 290 тисяч це говорить про те що
виявили бажання майже 87 тисяч
випускників минулих років наш вступник
цього року став більше обізнаний в своїх
правах і обов'язках я сподіваюсь що під
час подання оригіналів документів це ще
раз наших вступників підтвердять приємно
відзначити що стабільність у основних
параметрів умов прийому також сприяла
відсутності будь-яких
непорозумінь міжступником родинами і
приймальними комісій окремо наголошу на
обсягах прийому на бакалавра що
викликала подекуди несправедливо
образливу
критику і безпідставні нарікання на
Міністерство Я вже казав якщо ми
пройдемо по цифрам сухої статистики
радянські роки 100 випускників середньої
школи 21 місце вищому навчальному
закладі в 2007 рік 100 випускників школи
32 місця вищих навчальних закладах
державного замовлення в 2009 році на 100
випускників школи 35 місць в
університетах державного замовлення в
минулому році 39 місць державного
замовлення на 100 випускників середньої
школи і в цьому році 55
бюджетних місць зазначив що при
визначенні державного замовлення в
умовах зменшення на 42% кількості
випускників нами враховувалась
перенасиченість ринку праці фахівцями з
певних спеціальностей тому обсяг прийому
за галузями знань менеджмент
адміністративання економіка
підприємництво було зменшено дуже
серйозно на 40 з лишнім відсотків а
соціально-політичні науки приблизно від
22 до 30%. зменшення обсягу прийому за
інженерно-технічними та
природничо-математичними напрямами
складає від трьох до 20%, що дасть змогу
не зупиняти підготовку кадрів для
інноваційного розвитку для технічного
прогресу держави
розміщені державного замовлення вищих
навчальних закладах працювали єдині
узагальнені підходи а не якісь
особистісні як дехто намагався подати і
для ілюстрації можу сказати що скажімо в
Київському Національному економічному
університеті імені Вадима Гетьмана
державне замовлення скорочення на 32%. в
Донецькому національному технічному
університеті на
31%. в той час як києво-могилянській
академії лише на 19%, що менше
показників по країні у Львівському
національному університеті імені Івана
Франка скорочено дерзамовлення лише на
12 відсотків в той час як у наприклад
Харківському національному університеті
імені Каразіна на 21% майже вдвічі
більше Чому Тому що в різних областях
різна кількість дітей закінчила школи я
думаю що давайте припинемо політизацію
навколо цього питання тому що 12%
Франківського університету і 21 карася
говорить про те що ніякої політики
ніякої метушні і ніякої регіональності
тут не відбувався це говорить про те що
найважливіший етап вступної кампанії
позаду він пройшов успішно зараз
проходить другий етап що розповсю-
розпочався вчора коли вперше знову-таки
всі в однаковий час об 11 годині всі
університети оприлюднили рейтингові
списки і тепер 5 днів мають родини і
самі абітурієнти їх родини визначитись
Куди вони подадуть оригінали документів
тому що зарахування відбувається лише на
підставі подання регіональних документів
незалежно від того як ви подавали заявку
особисто письмово чи в електронному
вступі це я ще раз кажу для тих хто
робив закиди по електронному вступу тому
що конкурс відбувається лише на підставі
оригіналів документів а форма подачі
заявки в цьому році була добровільною на
вибір абітурієнта я дякую вам за увагу і
готовий відповісти на ваші запитання